[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jay billis joining us the espn college
basketball analyst did you watch what
happened at the academy awards last
night jay
i just saw it on social media and uh the
the there were two things that popped
out to me one was was in the sports
context the only thing i could think of
was jim everett going after jim rome
actually that was on our on espn air i
think when jim rome had a had a tv show
on espn2 i think
and then the other was when david stern
almost took a swing at you during the
nba draft that is true uh i think he
really if he was within reach that would
have been a slap
good call with romy and uh and jim
everett chris everett
yeah yeah that was that was so
ridiculous to play like what you like we
don't know that professional athletes
can kick our ass anytime
we know
uh you are 15th in our bracket challenge
your final four arizona gonzaga kentucky
and wisconsin
uh how do you explain yourself jay
uh well
there's one area where i was right dan
and that is before the tournament
started i had said that there was nobody
truly powerful this year like we had
last year with gonzaga and baylor
uh so i felt like there was going to be
some volatility but but i think i said
there were eight teams only that could
win this thing and that was it
and there are a bunch of teams that can
get through their bracket get to an
elite eight that can happen uh now did i
see st peters coming no and would i have
like if they if they replayed that if
they put that back on the board kentucky
st peters and i knew the outcome i still
might take kentucky because it seemed so
crazy that that would happen
but but um but i really i really believe
that that our sweet 16 this year
was 13 power conference teams
gonzaga and houston both in the final
four last year and the only real little
guy was st peters
and so while while we were celebrating
st peterson we should and we should
we'll always remember that and always
celebrate it you know the idea that it's
that anybody can win this thing anybody
can win a game
and anybody can can get through a
bracket if something happens in your
bracket but winning the whole thing is a
different ball game and uh and i think i
think we see that in the final four that
we have yeah because i've said this
before that we sort of love those
stories we love the madness but it's
really hard to win six consecutive games
unless you play in a conference where
you're playing tough opponents every
single night and you're going to go
against different styles saint peter's a
wonderful team and they were sort of
creating you know the atmosphere that
you had to adapt to them but you know
eventually you're going to run into
these teams i mean north carolina that's
a damn good team and i think we missed
the headline when they beat north
carolina or beat duke at uh duke with
coach k's last game because i kept i
came away going nobody's talking about
north carolina's performance they're
talking about how could duke lose at
home for those who haven't seen north
carolina how would you explain that
well
as you know they have a new coach this
year hubert davis his first year as a
head coach but but he's 50 years old and
has been in the game forever and he's
got a crazy experience in basketball
and i think early on they had a
different way of playing than carolina's
played in the past
it's more a spread offense a lot of ball
screens
pick and roll stuff pick and pop stuff
and they've got a stretch four in brady
manic who transferred in from oklahoma
who knocks down threes
so it's not the traditional carolina
team that pounds you inside with two
traditional low post guys
and they they pound the glass and people
seem to forget that carolina
they got into the tournament last year
but wisconsin blew their doors off in
the first round i mean they beat him by
like 30.
so it wasn't like like hubert davis
inherited this great team
so early on they struggled and when they
played really good teams like purdue
tennessee villanova they got beat bad
like 20 point losses and and at one
point in their losses they were given up
over 90 points a game and it was
probably toward the end of january dan
where they started to bow up and fight
back and i think hubert davis i remember
him telling me this before the that last
duke game and camera and coach k his
last game in cameron
he said he had told the team i think it
was some sort of bible verse you can
tell how much i'm reading the bible
these days but but
he said he said we have to plant our
feet stand our ground and fight
and that's the that's who they've been
ever since and uh and they're they're
very good they're not playing like an
eight seed i know that uh and they're
formidable because they have size and
they made saint peter's look frankly
like a mac team
uh which they didn't look like against
purdue and in kentucky and murray state
they looked they looked a lot better
than that and carolina made him look
pretty average i mean they scored what
they they didn't score 50 points in that
game didn't even threaten to score 50.
uh carolina took him apart it was it
wasn't even close
i thought maybe that final game at
cameron endor for that duke team
the moment was too big for them
and and maybe they didn't understand the
enormity of it and and you know you're
almost given 100 points up to north
carolina it feels like they're growing
up right before our very eyes where
they do understand the magnitude of this
that they know the next game could be
the last game for coach k because man in
the final five minutes of some of these
games
they hit big shots they i mean coach k
you could hear the emotion like he's
watching them grow up before his very
eyes
yeah it's there there's there's part of
this stand that's kind of hard to
explain because i don't think it was
just the last game against north
carolina i mean you know commentators
like me
had been saying earlier in the year this
is an old school defensive team duke
defensive team you know getting out and
passing lanes disrupting and you know
you look at their numbers they're going
they don't force any turnovers at all
really um they they were a very low
turnover forcing team i mean they're
good defensively but they weren't great
and especially toward the end of the
year i mean they they got taken apart by
north carolina in the second round or
excuse me in that last game and then
they went to the acc tournament and i
don't think they played very well there
at all like you know they beat they beat
syracuse in miami and then and then they
got taken apart pretty good by by
virginia tech which carolina did too
but uh but they didn't look good and i
didn't have them advancing past texas
tech in the bracket because of how they
looked and how i felt they were playing
and i know i wasn't alone in that
so your point about growing up before
our eyes i think they probably did some
growing up in practice
when they got back from uh from brooklyn
from the acc tournament
but but they're playing and like if you
were blindfolded the whole year and
dropped into the postseason only in the
ncaa tournament you just watched
tournament games
like i would say they've looked the best
of any team in the tournament like
nobody's played consistently as well as
they have through the four games that
have been played now that doesn't mean
it's going to carry over to next week
and honestly i can't imagine
you know how all the baggage of duke
carolina playing in the semi-final and
all the attention that's going to go
with that is going to affect play
and and affect the winner in the
championship game because there's one of
those two teams going to the title game
and uh and i wouldn't mind being kansas
right now saying uh you guys go have
your little hatfield mccoy match and go
go to as many overtimes as you want
we'll play the jp game and see on monday
night and and quietly go into that
because how many times have we seen this
where
we think the de facto champion's playing
in one semi the winner that's going to
going to win the thing or one gets more
attention and then and then a team out
of the other bracket winds up winning
well it's like the alcs when the red sox
and o4 beat the yankees and then we
thought well
they're of course going to win the world
series which they did against the
cardinals but we thought that was the
world series we're talking to jay bilas
who's joining us on the program
um
i have to admit i saw i tuned in
during commercial break and i saw the
commercial with
spike lee
and uh barkley's in there
and samuel jackson and then it's jim
nance with the bald head
i thought it was you for a second
do you take that as a compliment
i think jim should
you got a nice noggin see i i don't
i if i go bald it's not going to look
good but uh i think it would look good
no i think you're i think you're under
valuing the power of the dome and you
know i i tried to hang on to it for as
long as i could
and i never got to any comb over stage
or anything like that but tried to keep
a little stubble up there and then i
finally said you know what i'm bald and
i got to live with it and i didn't want
to have the wrap around hair that that
old guys do
you know when you when you're completely
uh you know completely bald up top but
you got a little got a little wrap
around thing whatever they call that i
didn't want to do that so i don't care
clearly i don't care what i look like
anymore
and my wife claims she's not going
anywhere so um i figured what the hell
and it is easier like it's so much
easier than uh than it used to be but if
you could have a full head of hair but
you were
five nine oh i take that in two seconds
for for two reasons one because hair is
great i mean i really enjoyed hair and
uh and i still have it in a baggie in my
bathroom drawer and i look at it every
once in a while but the other part is
i'm six foot eight inches tall and
finding pants is not an easy thing i
would like to be able to go into a store
and just get a pair of pants but every
time i walk into a store and look at
pants they're like nope not going to
happen
and
so i'd like to be able to get a pair of
pants i would just wear your warm-ups
from duke
those don't fit anymore those were a
little tight back in the day and uh my
kid wore them for halloween one year
and uh and it was grotesque um i can't
believe the crap we were like the little
short shorts and all that stuff uh it
was not it wasn't a good look did you
ever get punched on the floor
i got elbowed a bunch um i don't know
that i ever no i never got punched i did
rick barnes reminds me this all the time
we played against george mason my
freshman year and a guy named carlos
yates who i think at the time was
leading the nation in scoring elbowed me
in the face and knocked my front two
teeth out
and because it was over the christmas
break i couldn't get them replaced right
away
so when my teammates and i would go out
the drinking age was 18 back then in
north carolina where we'd go out at
night during the holiday break um all my
teammates would introduce me to good
looking girls
like hey me my friend jay and i'm like
really you know and and i look like uh i
look like a hockey player it was really
bad
you didn't meet your wife then did you
i met her after that after i got my
teeth fixed i i met my wife and uh but
but i had hair back then i had a lot of
one for me you had good hair
i had great hair it was spectacular yeah
it was you go back to the white shadow
when you make your cameo
and you that that that guy killed back
he slayed back then surfer here
i don't really call it a cameo dan it
was really a starring role i played
larson of oak ridge high where rhys
transferred to oak ridge
an all-white high school
and uh it was really moving when he took
his uniform off at the end and went back
to carver while we were warming up
uh and i i thought all those guys i
don't know if we've talked about this
before but i thought all the actors in
that were around our age i was like 16
maybe
um and when we did that and uh and all
of them were like smoking during breaks
they were all like in their 30s
and none of them could play dead the
only guy that could play was the actor
that played coolidge
all the other guys were were actors only
and could not play at all
great to catch up with you as always and
uh you'll be calling the games uh espn
international
yes i've been working on all my
different languages and my nil deals and
latvia are coming in you wouldn't
believe it it's unbelievable i'm very
proud of you jay you've come a long way
thank you jay
thanks dan that's jay billis espn
college basketball analyst i'll be
calling the games for espn international